the jurogan experience this is the
greatest time
in human history where there's
absolutely zero thinking when i say zero
thinking and or you're put in fear
of thinking i'll give you a little
example okay i had
i came in i had to have a covert test
before i walked in here right
so talk to your nurse and and um i said
i had it i had in december and i didn't
tell anyone because i didn't put on
social media and i put it everywhere
because i didn't want people like oh i'm
gonna cancel
shows and blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah is the hysteria that goes how
bad was it
it was like a very mild sinus infection
basically it's what jamie on basically
it started it started in my nose
all right and then i had a little like i
had one of those but i immediately
from the past anytime i get sick i'm
traveling so i know
i've had i've been sick on the road i
merely put a nose spray
constant cleaning and i have a um
inhaler
like a steroid to get my lungs going so
i started that
the next day body felt like i was
getting something and which i've had in
the past almost
if i i don't get the chills my my skin
gets really
sensitive and then after that
a little tired but i had i can breathe
but clearly i had a sinus
infection that's the best way to
describe it now here's the thing
and i gave it to my wife and my youngest
daughter
and the other two brought my other two
daughters like we're out of here we're
getting tested they both
negative soon they left the house we're
out of hair and they got bubbles around
the head and
wearing their space outfits so they're
gone
my youngest one comes home from school
and she has to take a test
and they say you're positive and she was
she clearly got sick
my wife's sick i'm sick now
none of us i i have an infectious
disease doctor
in new jersey his specialty is
infectious disease
as a doc my daughter is positive
i clearly gave it to her he goes you
need to get tested before i see you
i said okay well it's a two three day
wait in the meantime did you have every
anything goes take vitamin c vitamin d
and zinc
because do you have a high fever i want
no because
you have trouble breathing oh no because
then don't worry about it
so part of me started getting infuriated
so you're telling me the world is
shutting down
and you're telling me to take vitamin c
vitamin d and zinc
because i need you to get the test
okay i'll get the test nah i'm a little
aggravated i just want something to get
rid of this
right okay that's all i want right so
now it's going on the second
week and it's this thing's annoying
because i'm taking
the 2000 d's and 3000 c's and
zinc and a and whatever he's telling me
to do
my daughter is getting better my wife
still can't
d can't smell or taste
um and she's got stage four cancer so
she's like super high
she's doing great and all that nothing
but she's doing great she's on the trial
she's crushing it so if anything she's
the most
danger because of her immune system
week two i get a test
the same test i just took here
which is a very reliable test
and i told my doctor hey man it's a
fistula test deposit which test did you
take
as i took the rapid because that i can't
i don't accept that one you don't accept
that
infectious disease doctor and you don't
accept
that test what did he want the pcr test
he wanted yeah whatever he's got to go
to a lab
now we're going on day 12.
are you still taking telling me to take
vitamins and stuff
so finally i said i'm not doing that
test because then i got to go in the
state and the system and
and they called looking for my daughter
can we speak to your daughter
no you may not well is she doing the
appropriate things
i have it as her father well what is she
doing
go [ __ ] yourself
that's what she's doing you don't call
my house
government you just overstepped your
boundaries
you're just here to protect me not to
come knocking on my door
to ask me what i'm doing and how i'm
treating my 16 year old
it's a very frightening place to be now
with that said
i then ask hey man what can we do
because
i need that other test and i'm not
getting the other test so i called a
friend
said i'll get you something by tomorrow
i got stuff by the next day and in two
days that stuff was clear
so i started asking her
why don't people and and i just
left the town of chester new jersey and
there was a um
there's a couple there's about 15 of us
a group
that formed this community during the
whole covid
and this one woman just got it and she
got hospitalized knowing whoa what
happened
and she said i waited 12 days
and then i had a problem i started
freaking out breathing
went to the hospital that gave me
steroids and antibiotics and it cleared
right up
so my question is
why do you have to test positive to wait
to get
antibiotics or steroids if neither one
of them hurt you or kill you
wow you're still waiting to see what
this does
and she didn't have an answer and she's
like that's a great question
like it's a simple it's just a question
so if i'm a doctor
and joe rogan comes to me and says hey
man my daughter's positive
i have sinus are you having trouble no
well i can give you this
because i know it's not going to kill
you and i know it's good i'll give you
antibiotics and hopefully in two three
days it will clear up
but it's not gonna and if it gets worse
then we'll take care of it then
because clearly this is not gonna make
you worse right
so why isn't that being done and then my
other question
was if that doctor
an infectious disease doctor doesn't
allow
that test how many people take that test
and it counts as a number
but yet it doesn't count so what is
really going on
is my question there's a lot of
confusion a massive amount of people
there's a disease that kills some folks
and there's a disease that
we in the beginning stages of this
pandemic
thought was going to be far more severe
than it turned out to be and they never
adjusted
that's the problem the problem is it's
still not good
you know you don't want to catch covet
but the vast majority of people who get
it will be fine
78 of the people that are hospitalized
are obese
these people have a real hard time with
it there's
six percent of the people who died from
kovid only had covet
six percent of the people who died from
covet only had coveted
the other 94 had an average of 2.6
comorbidities so almost three
more than two and a half comorbidities
being like obesity
you know there's a bunch of different
things that people have diabetes is a
big one
um you know uh alzheimer's there's a lot
of
there's a lot of like comorbidities that
are that are very dangerous if you get
coveted i'll tell you another one so
another one of our friends
his name is rob he's heavy he's a mess
bro
gout three times he's a mess he's
totally heavy dude blah blah blah yeah
july he says don't come near me i have a
sinus infection
and we all wait rob's off limits
rob's diet we're laughing rob died he's
got he's done
we said you should really go check that
out rob
we don't hear from rob next time
next thing me and me and my wife went to
maine where i
went on a mountain we were on we we're
on a lake
one i felt like i was in if i die that
is where heaven's gonna be is that trip
with my wife
i come back do you hear what's going on
rob what he's in the hospital what
he's trying to he's on the uh the
penalty the ventilator one
what now he was a crazy trump guy
he was like drop drop full-blown i would
go there like oh my god these guys are
talking politics again
please get off that every morning
the liberal is a democrat as a non-stop
like oh my gosh want to have a muffin
and relax
so with that and i dude i got caught up
too right
i would be a liar if i said i wasn't
caught up in some stuff for a while i
was on the internet like
dude my dude jfk is coming back i was
holding my
of course makes all such a while i was
i i was in right
but this guy was like if i ever get i'm
taking hydrochloroquine
all right that was that's so now
and this is all still going by the way
he gets admitted to the hospital and
here comes my next question
and there is an ending to this story um
he gets admitted they say he's got brain
damage
from coven his brain damage well this is
the information we're getting like what
never what do you mean he's brain down
yeah he's he's not gonna he's not gonna
be able to walk
what he says brain damage then it turned
out he had strokes
the cove had caused strokes then it
turned out
no he asked for
a specific drug they said we can't give
it to you
in the state of jersey and we're gonna
have to do
testing before it could do stuff next
thing you know
the guy's on high blood pressure pills
and all that they didn't give him his
meds
he stroked out oh cut two
he's brain dead his wife can't
his wife and 11 year old 13 year old
half
have to say goodbye to him before they
pull the plug they're not allowed to be
with him
they have to facetime so here's a
question for you no
this is going somewhere bro right
thank god one of our crew said
please send this person there just to
one last
one last look the specialist shows up
said he's not
brain dead he's dehydrated
who's been taking care of this patient
and who said he was
covered i want everything gets
everything said i need the wife
and children in here oh well it's
against our foot
again what's keeping you safe what's
keeping you safe
bring his family in here his family
talks to him
his heart rate starts going up in a week
he opens his eyes
and communicates for the first time it's
six weeks later he now stands up for the
first time
it was uh it was october
he finally got out and he's still taking
physical rehab
i got pictures of him videos of him and
all that jazz
but he's recovering so the point of my
story is two things
they were ready to let him die they were
willing they already said he's dead
and you can't visit him jesus christ so
what
where kind of [ __ ] hospital is this
it's in new jersey
that's crazy so i'll so but my question
is this when it comes to not being able
to see elderly in elderly homes you got
a quarantine and all that
what keeps the workers safe what keeps
the quote heroes
safe and what
why can't you allow someone with a human
touch
because when you're when you're at your
weakest moment in time
you need a human you need pure love
you need that child you need your mother
to come visit you they're the ones
even if you're in your house and the
fact that they are stopping that
is pure evil in my mind i don't it has
nothing to do with safety
and if it is safety then stupidity
and if i and at
i think in the general sense they're
trying to protect people from getting
infected
well what keeps the people that works
there infected nothing well then what
what they're going to do the tightest
masks that you can but there's other
things
you can give it to the child and the mom
and dad exactly no i'm with you i'm with
you 100
if your kid was dying joe yeah you're
going to allow them to keep you from
seeing them
no no i'm going to do my best right
you're gonna smash that door
down bro i'll tell you that right now
you're gonna have to arrest me
yeah you're gonna have to rest me so i i
feel the same way i know what you're
saying
you gotta question everything there's
but you're right about the touch
about love and about having hope and
having someone come visit you
despair is terrible for the immune
system all that stuff is
do you know what a nocebo is you know
what that means no it's the opposite of
placebo a placebo effect is they give
you a sugar pill
and it makes you think that you're doing
well and you're like oh and then all
sudden your symptoms improve and you
actually get better
because your body is on a positive
trip right your body's like oh jim got
the medicine
ah we're healing up and it literally has
a
an actual physical measurable effect and
it's called the placebo effect well
there's also
something that they believe is more
powerful than the placebo effect
and that's the nocebo effect the nocebo
effect is telling
someone that they have a disease telling
someone
that there's an incurable disease or
that they're sick
and then they [ __ ] panic now here's a
perfect example
in 2007 there was a guy that was a part
of a trial
that they were doing a double-blind
placebo-controlled
trial on antidepressants so they're
trying to find the efficacy of
antidepressants
and they give this guy um these pills
and he shows up at the hospital he's got
an empty bottle of pills
and he goes help me help me i took all
the pills i took all the pills
and this guy collapses all right they
bring him into the emergency room
his [ __ ] hot blood pressure is
dangerously low
his heart rate is jacked up he's pale
he's sick
they're like oh no and so they they find
the guys
uh he the guy has a pill bottle they
brought in with him they find the guy's
physician that's a part of the clinical
trial
and they bring the physician in the
physician tells him
you got the placebo there's no
medication here
this is these are [ __ ] pills there's
nothing in them
all of a sudden the guy gets better like
that his
his heart rate balances his blood
pressure
balances 15 minutes later he's fine the
power
of your mind he was convinced that he
was [ __ ]
if you have someone in a hospital bed
and you're telling them they're going to
die
and you're not going to see your family
and the amount of stress
and the pain your symptoms will crash
everything will get
more [ __ ] up your body will go into a
total state of shock
there's been people that have died
because they were
incorrectly diagnosed with cancer
and they went into this this shock where
they can't believe that
they're not gonna and then their their
immune system crashes their body crashes
and then they've done autopsies and they
found out that it was benign
and this is what drives me nuts where
nobody questions you just go
uh that's what they say that's where
that's what they said so that's what
we're doing
that's what voodoo is you know like
people think that voodoo is [ __ ]
what voodoo is is you tell someone if
you're a charismatic person you have
white paint on your face and [ __ ]
feathers and
skulls and on sticks and you tell them i
put a curse on you and you believe that
[ __ ] you'll be in a
full terror yeah you'll be in full
terror and then your life will fall
apart
my hand to god when i start my show
i say and i've been saying this is the
greatest voodoo trick i've seen in
humanity
in my entire life because that's what it
is
it's the greatest voodoo trick in
history i it's mind-boggling
now i'm able to i'm able to sit and
watch it
and and dodge from it but at the same
time
i i'm i'm baffled
how many people just
don't question anything it's
mind-boggling
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience